today's the day I'm going to be ranking
the best laptops for Architects and help
you pick the best one for you let's get
started with this list the ti system
begins with f being the absolute worst
all the way up to S being the premium
must have wallet burning choice to
ensure you can use this same strategy
for any laptop we will rank them based
on the following criteria one to five of
course price battery life graphics
screen quality and compatibility for
this video each laptop had to meet a
series of prerequisites to even be
considered I'm sure there will be strong
disagreement in the comments below about
my selections but nonetheless each had
to have a minimum of a 14-in screen 1
tbte of a solid state hard drive a
minimum of 32 GB of RAM and of course a
minimum of i7 processor or equivalent
now that you know the rules let's get
into it first on our list is the Dell
XPS 15in here in Australia it's priced
at
$4,99 off the shelf which means it's a
relatively expensive laptop All Things
Considered with one being the cheap
laptop and five being the most expensive
this definitely gets a number four Dell
has always been one of my favorite
laptops because they just produce high
quality good laptops that last a long
time this XPS has a 16-hour battery life
if you're running the screen in full HD
mode or 7h hour battery life on the OLED
display which let's be honest you're
buying a high quality laptop you're
going to be staring at it for the full
battery life so you're going to be
running it on o LED screens meaning
you're only going to get a 7h hour
battery life so we're going to give it a
score of three it also comes with an RTX
4060 8 GB graphics card now overall this
is a good graphics card in a laptop it
can handle most of the heavy lifting
however it's not the best graphics card
it's only 8 GB and if you're doing some
more high-intensive R tracing renders
you're going to struggle a little bit
that's why I've also given this one a
ranking of three like I mentioned in the
battery life a OLED screen is present
which is quite good we'll skip over this
give it a four and move on of course
being a Windows based laptop it can
handle almost every single program Under
the Sun so straight away we're giving
that a five to round it up to an a level
laptop the Dell XPS start our list
extremely strong moving on to the
relatively brand new Apple MacBook Pro
with the M3 Max chip now this is the
first time Apple has come into the game
and allowed us to do Hardware
accelerator race tracing which makes it
an excellent architectural laptop
however being an excellent laptop as
well as an Apple product means it's
going to be damn expensive here in
Australia $
5,599 will get you one of these ready to
go now that's an extremely expensive
price so we're we're going to slap a
score of five the battery life is
incredible of course Apple laptops are
known to have phenomenal battery lives
on this device you can expect up to 18
hours of battery life which again will
give it a score of five the hardware
accelerator rate tracing we spoke about
is a unified 32 GB memory which means
you do have a better graphics memory per
se but you may not be able to produce
the top high-end renders so for this
reason we're going to give it a four now
as you can probably tell behind me I am
a little bit of Apple Fanboy I do have a
few products because the quality of
their displays is phenomenal this
MacBook Pro comes with an xdr display
it's similar to the display behind me so
straight away I'm giving it a five
because it is by far the best screen
I've ever used in my life lastly apple
is not user friendly it is not
compatible with everything which makes
life a little bit of a problem when
you're trying to do architecture if
you're running Revit scrap this computer
completely unless you want to install
parallels if you're running D5 render
once again get rid of this computer from
your list because you can't actually run
them there are a few more programs like
this so be sure to check your systems
are compatible with apple before you buy
this laptop because it could be a very
very expensive mistake for that reason
it can run almost everything but a few
selected programs it can't and therefore
I give it a score of 4 even though with
that unfortunate ending this Apple
MacBook Pro still ends up up in our top
s tier if you're new to the channel
let's have a quick little intrude and
get to know each other first of all my
name is David tomich I'm rad architect
here in Western Australia and my goal is
to give you as much architectural
content as humanly possible I want to
reveal the industry secrets that people
are not sharing the things that you do
not learn at University that you do not
get taught in the real world that you
just have to find out through trial and
error that's what this channel is for
that's what we've been doing for the
past 4 years the goal for 2024 is to
grow this channel as much as we possibly
can so we want to take it from about
46,000 where it stands today all the way
up to 100,000 subscribers I'm hoping
that you're going to be able to help us
with that goal by simply smashing the
Subscribe button down below and that's
it that's all we have to do if you're
interested in more of what I do there is
a link down below to my website
david.com.com for those that are new to
the architecture game to architectural
project trackers for Excel that can
calculate every dollar from the Builder
quote and of course if you've
accelerated your architectural career
you're starting your own projects there
is a full custom architectural brief
available for you to use with your
clients to be able to pinpoint the exact
project the exact needs of every single
person that walks in your door so far I
hope you've enjoyed the content let's
keep going moving on to our Lenovo Idea
pad 5 now the this is a cheaper laptop
in our series which is perfect for a
beginner or an introductory Series where
it's not on special you can pick one up
for about
$1999 however at the moment you can pick
it up for just under ,500 which is a
phenomenal 25% saving so overall we'll
give it a score of two because the price
is relatively cheap the battery life on
the other hand again you're paying less
so you're getting less you get a maximum
of 9 hours of battery life from this
device easy score one that's not even
going to get get you through a full
workday as an architect so a 9-hour
battery life is just not going to cut it
for us AMD raisin 7 is inside as the
graphics Processing Unit which
unfortunately in this particular
instance isn't compatible with even
running high-end rate tracing on
something like twin motion that's a
score of two for me unfortunately the
screen quality once again IPS that is
such dated technology that is going to
be so blurry when you compare it to
anything straight up score of two it is
not looking world for this Lenovo Idea
pad unfortunately the best thing about
it of course is it is windows again so
it's compatible with everything but you
won't be able to do any high quality
raid tracing on this which is a complete
lead down without good quality ra
tracing your renders are going to be
poor your images are going to be poor
your marketing is going to be poor so we
give that a score of two as a result
that gives the Lenovo Idea pad a grade
of D it is the worst on our list so far
and I'm really hoping the next two come
in a lot higher than this one right now
next we have the MSI Creator M16 now
this is a brand new laptop that's just
recently hit the market again it can be
yours for
$3,299 which is a pretty okay price in
this General tiered list so I'm going to
give it a score of three it has a
terrible terrible battery life though 5
hours it is designed to sit on your desk
and literally be plugged in the whole
time so we're going to give it a score
one and move on what's worse is it has
an RTX 4050 6 GB graphics card that's
just going to get you across the line to
do bare basic rate tracing so score
three it could get it done but it's not
going to do it well the screen itself is
a full HD screen which again is
incredibly incredibly dated for a brand
new piece of technology which is
intended for the gaming market now
gaming laptops are usually incredible
architecture laptops in this case score
or 2 absolutely no way but like I said
it is Windows it's compatible with most
things score five make sure that this
MSI Creator laptop comes in at a B score
and puts it amongst the top three last
but not least we have the Asus Rog scar
18 once again brand new laptop
exceptional but also very very expensive
this laptop comes in at full price at
$7,499 so a score of five is only
fitting as it is the most expensive
laptop on this list again like our MSI
it only has a 6-hour battery life which
is a little bit better than the MSI so
we'll give it a score of two it has an
RTX 4090 16 GB graphics card it's most
likely the best across all of these
computers for architectural
visualization which means we have to
give it a score of five it is the best
it is the most powerful and it is one of
the latest chips you can get in one of
these laptops unfortunately the screen
is a Quad HD screen better than our last
two but not as good as the MacBook Pro
so we're going to have to give it a
score of four and of course a score of
five compatibility because it works with
all of the software you're going to need
as an architect overall that puts our
Asus Rog laptop at the top in line with
our MacBook Pro so if you're looking to
buy a Windows or an Apple device you
have two choices right here both
phenomenal both very very expensive but
you also have a couple safer options if
I was going for a budget friendly
version personally I'd probably pick
something like the Dell XPS 15 in
however if I had a bit more luxury and a
bit more freedom financially I'd
probably be steering towards the MacBook
Pro simply for great resale value later
down the track anyway that's all for me
team thank you so much for watching hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below for more weekly content